never before in human history have we
been richer more advanced more powerful
and yet we feel overwhelmed in the face
of rapid climate change
it seems simple on the surface
greenhouse gases trap energy from the
sun and transfer it to our atmosphere
this leads to warmer winters harsher
summers dry places become drier and wet
places wetter countless ecosystems will
die while the rising oceans swallow
coasts and the cities we build on them
so why don't we just like prevent all of
that
well
it's complicated
the public debate about stopping rapid
climate change often focuses on a few
key features like coal plants cars or
burping cows
and so the solutions are often
simplistic
rows of solar panels biking to work
something something sustainability and a
huge talking point is personal
responsibility how you should change
your lifestyle to prevent rapid climate
change which we'll find out together in
the next few minutes
this is one of those videos where we
want to encourage you to watch to the
end because to discuss real doable
solutions we first need to understand
the problem
[Music]
a fuller picture
modern industrial society as we
constructed it in the last 150 years is
inherently destructive to the planet
basically everything we do to make our
lives easier safer and more comfortable
is making things worse for the biosphere
the food we eat the streets we walk on
the clothes we wear the gadgets we use
the way we move around and the pleasant
temperatures we artificially create
around us
while most people know about the serious
impact of energy beef cars and planes
many major polluters are barely ever
talked about
the emissions leaking out of landfills
are as significant as the emissions of
all the jets in the air
more co2 is released to run our homes
than from all cars combined and the
emissions produced when making a new car
is equivalent to building just two
meters of road
so it is nice to switch to electric cars
but they won't solve anything if we keep
building roads the same way
fixing one small part of the industrial
system is not enough
each of the many different parts needs
its own solution and many of them aren't
straightforward
but even where we know what to do just
because a solution exists doesn't mean
we're able or willing to implement it
there are many grey areas in the fight
against rapid climate change the most
prominent one is the divide between rich
and poor
emissions versus poverty
there is a clear connection between the
prosperity of a nation and its carbon
emissions in other words richer people
tend to cause more emissions so the key
to fixing climate change is simply for
the world's richest to cut back on their
extravagant lifestyles right
while this would help it wouldn't make
the problem go away
this is because 63 of global emissions
come from low to middle income countries
countries where most people are not
living extravagantly but are trying to
escape poverty at worst and achieve a
comfortable lifestyle at best
the unfortunate reality is that
currently escaping poverty and becoming
middle class creates unavoidable
emissions
so asking developing countries to cut
emissions just looks like an attempt to
keep them down
it's very hard to argue that a region
should protect their primeval forests
and spend money on solar panels instead
of burning wood when it can't meet basic
needs for significant parts of its
population
but cutting back is not a popular demand
especially if the countries making these
demands got rich by causing
environmental damage in the past
so for billions of people more emissions
are a good thing personally
when we forget about this we tend to
propose unworkable solutions
take concrete eight percent of co2
emissions are released by the concrete
manufacturing industry
okay cool stop using concrete right
but right now concrete is also a cheap
and easy way for growing populations in
developing countries to build affordable
housing
and there are many examples like that
even rich countries aren't immune from
disagreeing about rapid climate change
solutions banning coal gas and oil from
the energy mixes slowed down by heated
discussions about what should replace
them
the citizens can be strictly against
nuclear power but also oppose wind or
solar infrastructure in their backyards
in principle all of these issues can be
overcome but there are things we don't
currently know how to overcome
the most problematic one is food
emit or die
we will soon need to feed 10 billion
people and we don't know how to do that
without emitting greenhouse gases
because of the nature of modern food
production that requires fertilizers or
manure it's impossible to have zero
emissions food
rice alone emits so much methane each
year that it practically equals the
emissions of all the air traffic in the
world what's worse is that the foods we
like the most emit the most
57 of food emissions come from animal
based foods although they make up only
18 of the world's calories and 37 of its
protein and as people across the world
grow richer they want more meat
traditional diets in most cultures were
primarily plant-based with a little meat
on top but with the rise of industrial
style meat production and factory
farming meat has become a staple food
a regular indulgence in developed
countries and a symbol of status and
wealth in developing countries
today about 40 percent of the world's
habitable land is used for meat
production in some form or another the
size of north and south america combined
this is land we could otherwise allow
native ecosystems to regrow like forests
in the amazon and suck carbon out of the
atmosphere but instead most of it is
used to feed animals
the available solutions are uniquely
able to make everybody on the political
spectrum rich or poor unhappy
meat is highly emotional and there are a
lot of what about his arguments floating
around
like comparing it to the worst sources
of emissions
in the end it's pretty simple eating
less meat alone won't stop climate
change but we also can't stop climate
change without eating less meat
the same holds true for other things
that are less crucial to our survival
but frankly not realistic to make go
away
like air travel oc shipping mining and
the production of devices that play
youtube videos
so what does this mean do we need to
give up our way of life and can the poor
never achieve it
can't some technology save us so we can
continue to drive our big cars and eat
meat every day
solutions versus expenses
in principle this technology already
exists
direct air capture of co2 draws carbon
dioxide from the air so that it can be
stored underground or transformed into
products
so why aren't we implementing it in
every industry everywhere
because with the technology we have
right now this would cost some 10
trillion dollars per year or half the
united states gdp
this money has to come from somewhere
and currently no one is offering it
just dumping these costs on massive
polluters like steel mills and coal
power stations would double the cost of
their products and so these industries
that operate on very tight profit
margins would go bankrupt
getting the government to pay for it
seems logical but a lot of state
resources are actually tied up doing the
opposite like subsidizing oil and gas
which seems counter-intuitive but
follows clear incentives
by artificially keeping fuel prices low
shipping and everyday goods are kept
artificially cheap too which has a major
social impact on billions of people
around the world
that creates political lobbies and
incentives that perpetuate a cycle that
makes it so hard to stop fossil fuel
production
meanwhile very costly solutions for a
far-off problem like carbon capture seem
like they can wait as technically nobody
benefits from it right now
some argue that a move away from
capitalism is the only solution to this
mess others insist that markets should
be even freer without any interventions
like subsidies and some suggest that we
need what's referred to as d growth and
to cut back as a species overall but the
truth is at least as of now no political
system is doing an impressive job at
becoming truly sustainable and none have
really done so in the past
we also don't have the time to figure
this out and do a lot of experiments we
must implement solutions now
not just to halt the release of all
possible greenhouse gases but also to
start reducing the amount of co2 in the
air
it's too late to just mend our ways we
have to actively correct our past
mistakes with every year we waste more
extreme changes will be unavoidable
okay let's take a deep breath
rapid climate change in the world we
live in are complicated so here is where
you dear viewer come in again
could you please fix the climate
a narrative of our time is that we are
all responsible for rapid climate change
that everyone needs to play their part
why don't you buy a new electric car why
don't you replace your gas stove with an
electric one
how about you double glaze your windows
stop eating meat and switch off your
lights
shifting responsibility from the largest
carbon emitters to the average person
you is much easier to do than solving
problems
there's an extra bonus if solving rapid
climate change sells a new product
if you don't have the money or time for
these things you should feel bad
it's an effective message because it's
true the quickest way to cut co2
emissions would be if all rich
populations on earth drastically change
their lifestyles and if the people on
the rise would not seek to achieve it
favoring the climate over comfort and
wealth
if you're able to watch this video that
includes you
but we've just witnessed a global
experiment in staying at home not using
transport and consuming less during the
coronavirus pandemic
and all it did was reduce co2 emissions
by 7 for 2020
asking average people to solve rapid
climate change breaks down when we look
at the scale of the problem
personal contributions towards reducing
greenhouse gas emissions are nice but
they are dwarfed by the systemic reality
of global emissions
the concept of your personal carbon
footprint was popularized by the oil
producer bp in a 2005 ad campaign
arguably one of the most effective and
sinister pieces of propaganda that still
seriously distracts all of us from the
reality of the situation
if you eliminated 100 of your emissions
for the rest of your life you would save
one second's worth of emissions from the
global energy sector
even the most motivated person can't
even make a tiny dent
when we put together the dangers of
rapid climate change the scale of
emissions and the lack of consensus over
how to solve it the challenge seems
insurmountable it can cause decision
fatigue and moral licensing where you no
longer feel bad about behaving in a
counterproductive way
we have struggled a long time with this
which is why this video took us so long
to make
so what can you actually do
there are many different takes and they
are passionately discussed we don't know
who's right so we can only offer you the
courts kazakh's perspective and opinion
opinion part what can you actually do
we need a different way to think and
talk about rapid climate change an
all-encompassing systemic approach
nothing less than changing the
fundamentals of our modern industrial
societies
as discussed in frustrating length the
personal responsibility angle is
overplayed
for systemic changes in technology
politics and the economy of this
magnitude we need to influence the
people at the levers
politicians need to know and feel
strongly that the people care that their
own success depends on tackling rapid
climate change
when governments and local politicians
are reluctant to change laws that affect
their biggest tax contributors or
campaign donors we need to vote them out
and vote in people who respect science
we need to hold them accountable for
implementing the most effective climate
change strategies
not waste our time with things like
banning plastic straws but by moving the
big levers
food transportation and energy while not
forgetting the smaller ones like cement
or construction
when industries fight against changing
their ways for fear of losses or an
honest attempt to protect their own we
need politicians to change the laws and
incentivize the deployment of existing
technologies and massively invest in
innovation for the fields where we don't
have great solutions yet
there's no reason that the profit
interests of industries could not match
the need to reduce carbon emissions as
much as possible
and if they still don't cooperate harsh
punishments and regulation need to force
or bankrupt them
it's still unrealistic the change of
that scope can be forced onto a
worldwide economy quickly enough because
many low carbon technologies still need
a lot of time and research which means
they're expensive
but more companies will make more
efficient carbon capture systems tasty
meat alternatives better batteries
cement alternatives and so on if there's
a clear and growing demand
and if you're affluent enough you can do
your part by investing in these things
right now while they're still expensive
these are the mechanisms that will drive
the prices down later on
so this is basically what you can do
vote at the ballot vote with your wallet
there are too many opposing interests
and complicated gray zones
in the end if we truly get the systemic
change we need everybody will be unhappy
about some aspect to it
only if we all accept that some
solutions will have negative impacts for
us can we have an honest conversation
and make progress
everybody will be a little unhappy and
that's okay this is the best you can do
you can deal with the reality of the
situation and promote your priorities
through your behavior and your actions
and while you do so you can eat less
meat fly less or get an electric car
not because you should feel guilty if
you don't or because you naively believe
that you alone can stop rapid climate
change but to do your tiny tiny part for
the systemic change we need
this video was supported by gates notes
the personal blog of bill gates where he
writes about global health climate
change and more
check out gatesnotes.com to learn more
about ways the world can work together
to reach zero greenhouse gas emissions
or use the link below and in the spirit
of transparency if you want to learn
more about how we handle sponsorships
like this one we also have a medium
article describing how we do it
thank you for watching
[Music]